hello everyone this video is an overview
of homework 2 which is on supervised
sentiment analysis and i would actually
think of it as an experiment in cross
domain sentiment analysis let's just
walk through this notebook and i'll try
to give you a feel for the problem and
our thinking behind it
so the plot is the usual one
we're going to introduce a task and
associated data
and help you with setting up some
baselines and doing error analysis and
that's all a lead into these homework
questions which are meant to help you
explore the data in meaningful ways and
also set up some additional baselines
that might inform
ultimately your original system which
you then enter into the bank off
fast overview we're doing ternary that
is positive negative neutral sentiment
analysis we're going to be dealing with
two data sets the stanford sentiment
tree bank and a brand new assessment
data set that is a dev test split of
sentences drawn from restaurant reviews
we're giving you for training the sst
train set and asking you to evaluate on
the sst dev and test uh and also on this
new dev test split of restaurant reviews
and that's the cross domain aspect of
this
you are completely unconstrained about
what you do in terms of bringing in new
data for training and doing things in
development the one constraint that we
really need to firmly impose here is
that of course the sst3 test set is a
public test set it's actually included
in your data distribution so that other
notebooks can run some baseline systems
and compare against the literature but
that test set is completely off limits
during development
it's really important that you do all
your development just on the dev splits
and completely ignore the fact that you
have a labeled version of the ss3 t3
test set
and as i say here
much of the scientific integrity of our
field depends on people adhering to this
honor code that is doing no development
on what is test data because test data
is our own only chance to get a really
clear look at how our systems are
generalizing to new examples and new
experiences so please keep that in mind
the rationale behind this assignment of
course is to help you get familiar or
re-familiarize yourself with core
concepts and supervise sentiment
analysis and the associated life cycle
of developing systems in this space
which involves writing feature functions
trying out model architectures hyper
parameter tuning and also possibly doing
some comparisons of models using
statistical tests to try to get a sense
for how much meaningful progress you're
making as you iterate on your system
design
and we're also trying to push here in
this notebook that error analysis can be
a powerful way to help you find problems
in your system and then address them
one more methodological note as you'll
see from this notebook i'm encouraging
you to use functionality in this sst dot
pi module which is part of our course
code distribution you're not required to
use it
really the only contract we need to have
with you is that your original system
have a predict 1 method that maps
strings to predictions very directly
but other than that you're unconstrained
i do want to say though that i think
sst.experiment is a flexible framework
for doing lots of experiments without
writing a lot of boilerplate code so it
should if you get used to it be a
powerful basis for you for doing a lot
of experiments which i think is crucial
to success here
we do some setup by loading a bunch of
libraries
and get a pointer to the data and that
brings us to the training set here so
this is going to load in a pandas data
frame you can see that we've got about 8
500 examples
do review the notebook covering this
data set here there are a bunch of other
options for this train reader in
particular you can decide whether to
keep or remove duplicates and you can
also decide whether you want to train on
the labeled subtrees that the sst
contains which vastly increases the
amount of training data you have which
will be very compute intensive but it
could be very productive this is also a
point to say
again that you are free to bring in
other training sets and in fact it might
be very productive to bring in the
dynacent
data set which is covered in a
screencast for this unit
that data set has a lot of sentences
from restaurant reviews and it was also
labeled in exactly the same way using
the same protocols as were used for
creating the development set of
restaurant reviews for this unit which
is importantly different i think from
the protocols that were used for the sst
so bringing in more traded training data
could help you not only with the cross
domain problem but also with the kind of
label shift that has probably happened
between sst and these new development
data sets that we're introducing
and that does bring me to the dev sets
here so we have sst dev that's also a
panda's data frame as well as this new
bake off data of restaurant reviews also
panda's data frame and here you can see
just three randomly chosen examples
example id the text of the sentence
the label which is either positive
negative or neutral and that is subtree
is always zero because these assessment
data sets have only full examples no no
labeled subtrees the way the ssd train
set does
and we can get a look at the label
distribution and i'll just mention that
the label distribution for the test set
is very similar
it has one noteworthy property which is
that it's highly skewed a lot of neutral
examples which i think is realistic for
actual data even review data and then
there is a skew toward positivity with
negative the smallest and this kind of
label imbalance i think is severe enough
that it might impact optimization
choices that you make
this next section here just sets up a
soft max baseline we use a unigrams
feature function this couldn't be
simpler we're just splitting on white
space and counting the resulting tokens
and then we have this very thin wrapper
around logistic regression and those are
the two pieces that come together to run
here an sst.experiment
a lot of information about your
experiment is stored in this variable
and what's being printed out is just a
summary classification report we have
sst dev and bake off dev as our two
assessment data frames the results for
each one of those are printed separately
here and then our bake off metric is
this mean of the macro average f1 scores
across the two data sets exactly these
two but of course at the bake off time
we'll be using the test sets
so you might be guided in sort of hill
climb on this number here while also
attending to these two numbers which are
contributing to it so for example you
can see here that as expected since we
trained on the sst we're doing better on
the sst dev by far than we are on the
new bake off data
the next section here just shows you
another kind of baseline and this is a
deep learning baseline and rnn
classifier our feature function is very
simple here because we just split on
white space and we rely on the rnn
itself to do all the featurization which
is like an embedding lookup and then
processing the example
so that's very simple and then the
wrapper is also very simple here we're
going to set the vocabulary for the
model the min count of two that seems
productive and then finally run the
experiment and the one thing that's
important here the one change is that
you set vectorize equals false here
unlike in the previous baseline we are
not using scikit-learn dict vectorizers
to process count dictionaries to get us
from features to feature matrices um
here we are feeding our examples
directly through into the model our
model expects token streams with no
messing about and so vectorized false
will give them a pass through all the
way to the model so remember that
otherwise this will all fall apart but
other than that it's exactly the same
setup let's run it here i've got some
timing information we're going to fast
forward through this because this takes
a little bit of time but you'll see a
report and i'm currently on just a very
old cpu-based mac so
this will give you a sense for the cost
of development for deep learning in this
space
all right our model's early stopping
criterion was met after 49 epochs
and here's our look at the results which
are kind of comparable to what we saw
with the softmax baseline
all right and that brings us to error
analysis which can be an important step
in improving your system i've written a
few functions that make use of all the
information that is encoded in the
return values for ssd experiment which i
hope packaged together everything you
need to do rich error analysis reproduce
your results and make use of your model
in downstream experiments
here we're going to use it for use this
function find errors
i've done a little bit of pre-processing
of the errors that were found and
package them together and then this cell
here is just an example of the kind of
things that you might do
here we're looking at cases where the
softmax model was correct the rnn was
incorrect and the correct label is
positive you could of course fiddle with
those parameters here
we've got 168 examples falling into that
class and then we could look at a sample
of the actual text and fall into that
group as a way of figuring out how these
models differ and maybe improving one or
both of them
all right and that brings us to the
homework questions and again these are
meant to help you explore the data and
set up some additional baselines that
inform original system development we're
going to start with one that's data
oriented i've called this token level
differences what i'm trying to do is
raise to your awareness the fact that
the sst data and the new restaurant
review data are just encoded in
different ways at the level of
tokenization this is mainly the result
of the sst being kind of the result of a
historical process beginning with pang
in lead 2005
and going on through the sst project
itself so there's some funny things
about it that i think could certainly
affect any kind of transfer from one
domain to the other and since you are
training on sst data
it's important to be aware of how it
might be idiosyncratic
so that happens here you write this
function get token counts and as usual
you have a test you pass the test
um you're in good shape
next question relates to the cross
domain nature of our problem training on
some of the bake off data in this
standard paradigm you are training on
ssd evaluating on sst and also this new
bake off data set of restaurant review
sentences
what would happen if you augmented your
training set with a little bit of data
from the development set of restaurant
review sentences you have might have a
hunch that's going to improve system
performance and this question here
simply asks you to
run such an experiment as usual you have
a test i think you will find that this
is very productive in helping your
system get traction on the new data and
that should be a clue as to how to do a
really good job in the bake off with
your original system
this next question here is about feature
representation a more powerful vector
averaging baseline this is a step toward
deep learning uh it builds on this
section of a notebook here
where essentially we average together
vector representations of words to
represent each example and those are the
input to a simple logistic regression
classifier
so those are nice low dimensional models
that tend to be quite powerful this
question is asking you to replace the
logistic regression with a shallow
neural classifier so maybe the more
powerful part here and also to explore a
wide range of hyper parameters to that
model to get a sense for which settings
are best for our problem
and that brings us to burton coding and
this is like one step further down the
line toward deep learning and
fine-tuning this question is simply
asking you to encode your examples using
vert in particular taking the summary
representation above the class token the
final output there as your summary
representation of the entire example and
those become presumably the inputs to
some downstream classifier or
potentially a fine tuning process
the idea that this is like one step
better than the vector averaging that we
just looked at you do not need to
conduct an experiment with sst you're
simply implementing this feature
function here
but since ssd experiment does make it
really easy to run experiments once
you've implemented the feature function
i would encourage you to choose some
classifier model and see how well this
does but as usual you have a test and
the test is just about the feature
function and it will make sure
you're using all these values correctly
and that brings us to the original
system and i just want to remind you
that you are unconstrained except for
the fact that you cannot make any use of
the sst test set during development the
labels for that are off limits but
everything else is fair game bring in
new training data try new model
architectures and so forth and so on
um we've given a few idea ideas here but
this is by no means meant to be
restrictive it's just meant to get the
creative juices flowing other than that
this is the same procedure as homework
one we want a description of your system
to inform the teaching team about what
worked and what didn't and it would be
great if you reported your peak score
which is the macro average of the two f1
macros f1 scores for our two data sets
that's on the development set there
and that brings us to the bake off and
again the bake off procedure is familiar
the one piece here the crucial piece is
that you write up a function a predict1
function that maps a text directly to a
prediction using your original system
now given two examples here
yours might be simpler depending on
whether or not you use the ssd
experiment framework or not
uh but that all comes together here with
create bake off submission where you
input that function
you won't need to change this output
file and you can see that this function
here loads in our two test sets which
are unlabeled
and uses your predict one function on
all of those examples here
and then writes a file which you then
upload to the auto grader to grade scope
that happens here so i just would want
to reiterate that
in all senses the test data labels are
completely off limits to us all the
development conceptually and otherwise
should happen on the development data